all right august is national dog month
if you ask me every month should be
national dog month but we are
celebrating the month the right way we
have caesar milan and ken airman of halo
caller here with us today you guys
thanks for being here thanks for having
us so let's talk about this caller what
does it do and why did you guys decide
to come together and create it
well
what happened is unfortunately my
niece's dog got out of their invisible
fence and was run over by a car oh no
and it was a major tragedy they had
rescued ruby and
when i looked up the statistics like
millions of dogs are lost and are hit by
cars every year it's awful and
technologically i knew that we could
come up with a solution that would work
and basically four years ago started on
that and i knew i needed the
dog expert to make sure it would work
for dogs and when he heard how many dogs
were lost
he was very supportive of the mission
and four years later
this is where we've come so it's pretty
impressive here you are now so tell us
how does the caller actually work
what does it do
okay so you basically go to a it work if
you know the invisible offense basically
every dog needs a fact you either want
to let them out
in a park or a pen
or your backyard
but unfortunately a lot of times the
door gets left open dogs get out so with
a map on your phone you can just draw
the points of your fence like a real
fence wow it gets downloaded to the
collar and when your dog gets near the
edge of the fence it's going to beep
that creates the boundary and then they
understand beep means fence now you can
take your dog with you anywhere that is
amazing i'm gonna need to get two of
these for my dogs at home and caesar for
you how does it feel to team up and
create such an incredible product that
not only helps dogs stay safe but for
families to obviously keep their pups
close to home well life is all about
safe peace love life is about trust
respect love life it's about connection
communication relationships so for me
i'm always teaching the humans right so
i do need tools that can enhance what
the human is learning because sometimes
people are not paying attention to the
rules the boundaries and limitations
everybody wants to practice follow play
explore we want to go outside be
followed by the dog play with the dog
but at the same time the dog needs to
need to be reminded about the rules
buying limitations otherwise the dog
goes into fight flight or avoidance
flight is when a dog runs away fight is
what people call aggression and avoid
this is when the people when the dog
doesn't listen to the human so we need
to make sure that the human has
something that that connects them to the
dog constantly so that's when i came in
and that's what halo can do that's what
it does with it being national dog month
you are the the best of the best the dog
expert so for all of us dog owners and
dog lovers what would you say what is
your number
one tip for keeping dogs just healthy
and happy at home well healthy is
definitely the worst exercise it plays a
big role as soon as they wake up in the
morning they don't want food or water
what they want is a long walk right most
people give breakfast to a dog as soon
as they woke up in the morning so as
soon as you wake up what you have is
energy what you need to do is burn it
and the way you burn it you come to work
right so yeah so dogs don't have a job
so their job is exercise and then they
need rules by limitation so when they
come home they need to know what is it
that you don't like
or you don't want from them right so but
the exercise place is such a big role in
order for the mind to learn that's why i
say exercise mental stimulation and then
is the affection so that will solve
everything by the way that is good to
know that is something i will definitely
take home with me thank you for being
here and also
super zoo that's what's going on this
week you're out there too as well right
that's exactly where we are this is this
is the makeup for that yes uh absolutely
well thank you guys for being here cesar
ken we appreciate it and mercedes i will
send it over to you